good evening and welcome to this
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
on Wednesday the 26th of October 2022.
my name is councilor Paula spencerley
and I am the vice chair of this
committee acting as chair tonight
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference the page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
so apologies for absence might have the
apologies for absence please Berner
yes German
we received apologies for absence from
counselors Bell heard and helm
thank you
so to a gender item three the minutes it
is recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 29th 28th of July
sorry 2022 found on pages five to ten
are approved as a true and accurate
record I so move do I have a seconder
for that motion please thank you
councilor Mays and can we agree that by
Ascent fantastic thank you
so we moved to um item four Declarations
of Interest
so to disclose the existence and nature
of any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regards to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
should also that they are also required
to disclose any such interests as soon
as they become aware should the need
arise throughout the meeting
so public participation a gender item
five I can advise if you've not received
any submissions from members of the
public
so we moved to item six which is to be
found yes
oh sorry yes any Declarations of
Interest no good thank you I should have
given given you a chance there thank you
very much so
um we moved to a gender item six which
is found on pages 11 to 20.
so this evening quite unusually as well
as chairing I'm going to be giving you a
little bit of um an oversight of this
report
um which I hope you hope you've all had
time to to look at fully
um
what we have
um first of all are there
recommendations to be found on page 11
of the report and I want to approach
these separately in the case of the
first recommendation I will read this
out now and then invite
um members to speak after I've I've
given you a little presentation of the
report doing it a little around the
other way because of the way it is so
um that the committee considers the
proposed outline response to the notice
of motion work plan item as a basis for
either providing assurance and making
recommendations to the council or other
committees or defining the scope for
actual scrutiny and engaging the working
group if any further Preparatory work is
required so don't need any seconder for
that because we've got to choose an
either or there so I'm going to give you
a little overview of what we did in the
working group of overview and scrutiny
we were looking at if you to just give a
little recap attack we were looking at
councilor fluka's motion with regard to
an appeal which we had lost and other
matters appertaining to that and to the
behavior of members and where and what
we could do with regards to the planning
process going forwards
so we so we did have a good look at this
and what we've what we've done is come
up with and you can see these on page 15
and 16. some conclusions and initial
responses that we're bringing forward
tonight to the committee
so the working group's initial
conclusion center around the following
elements and what we've tried to do here
is be positive and take this forward to
actually bring about some improvement
hopefully in the processes
um around planning to try to avoid
similar similar occurrences in future to
best protect against them
so a constitutional intervention or
break
to enable planning and legal officers to
review the implications of Officer
overturns on strategic and other
applications before a decision is
finalized
the review and promotion are fresh of
the planning appeals protocol and also
the planning guidance on decision making
set out in the consultation
Constitution even
identification of further member
training issues and a review of the
style approach of Officer reports
on planning applications to give greater
balance of argument to assist members as
we know that's something that comes up
very regularly
so on the list above on the first of the
list above the context for this for a
constitutional intervention would be the
balance between the speed of
determination and quality of decisions
and a clearer understanding of the need
to substantiate the overturning of an
officer's professional recommendation
and the risks involved there is clear
evidence that a number of authorities
have a mechanism of this nature and
options appear to include
and there's a bullet point list here
which I'm quickly going to go through
because I think this one is probably the
most controversial of the suggestions
that you have before you
um introduction of concepts of minded to
approve refuse motion based on a clear
if not detailed reason
delegate decision to director in
consultation with chairman Vice chairman
with backstop of reference back to
original committee
officers request deferral in exceptional
cases or solicitor being the Arbiter of
issues and requesting deferral for
further advice and consideration
a committee decision to defer for this
precise reason area committees automatic
referral to District planning committee
on overturns a single Planning
Development control committee would
enable establishment of a planning
referrals committee and that's obviously
a very controversial suggestion and I
know that a lot of members have strong
feelings
about some of these strengthening the
planning appeals protocol with members
leading on statements and evidence and
with minded two deferrals only those
present at the original committee may
vote at subsequent meeting if the
application was referred back
stronger and recorded reasoning for
departure from the officer
recommendation or giving different
weight to material considerations so it
goes on analyzing the first bullet point
list I gave you so going back to drawing
you back to page 15 the five bullet
points at the top now I'd also at 0.7
here draw your attention back to the
working group's initial conclusions
center around the following elements and
I would really underscore there in
presenting this the word initial these
really are initial conclusions
in my own opinion is that um I'm not
sure that we're at a place at the moment
where we would take these forward to
another committee or to four Council but
that's obviously for members to decide
this evening
um the working group would certainly be
very pleased to welcome these back
um so that we can do further work on
them so this is really a report on what
on the things that we've come up with so
far going back to council the fluca's
original motion you may remember there
were also other elements to it such as
the attendance of members at planning
appeals and that that work needs to be
looked at um too
and going down to the training elements
the review style approach of um planning
reports I also think there's a lot of
work to be done there with regard to
looking at
um potentially reports from other other
um authorities that kind of thing
so we don't want to do the work of PG a
but at the same time I think we have to
have anything we put forward that's my
opinion not not you know you can give
yours in a moment members
um but I wouldn't want to be putting
forward anything that was
um not fully
um scrutinized for one of a better way
so I'm going to open it up now to to
members so yes councilor Morgan thank
you madam
this proposal is going to be quite a
significant change to the way that
planning committees have I mean under
the short period of time I've been on
them uh I can see that that's gonna and
therefore I don't think
we can take this forward without a
considerable amount of thought and so I
would suggest that this goes back to the
working group for further consideration
before we're in a position to bring I
mean obviously it's something that full
council is going to have to decide
exactly and I don't think it's in quite
in that state to go there just yet
exactly I I agree with you on that um
councilor Morgan
on this place
councilor Huebner
yes I agree with what uh
with what you're saying and I think
um we're not ready to take this to the
main
Council so uh yeah I I propose that we
take this back to the
uh working group The working group
fantastic do I have a seconder for that
proposed by councilor Morgan thank you
so can I agree that by Ascent members
okay so it um Stuart
um is is that in order
[Music]
fine or condensed swapped what it Wishes
the working group to address in more
detail I mean the the bullet points that
you refer to there
um about Ways and Means of providing
this constitutional uh break or
intervention are many have varied and
um to do work preparing for all of those
may may seem a little bit sort of uh
evil data it'd be far better if we could
sort of
find two messages to concentrate on I
just if not we'll we'll look at them all
in the round but I just wonder whether
members at this stage want to
perhaps X by a little bit discretion
over what might be better than others
just of pursuing greater detail that's
all okay well that I refer members I'll
I'll come to you councilor Morgan
shortly so I refer members back to the
bullet point list that's on page 16. so
these refer to just as just as a quick
explanation of what Mr Jennings has said
there these refer to
um the first of the bullet points on
page 15 at seven which is a
constitutional intervention or break to
enable planning and legal officers to
review the implications of office
overturns on strategic and other
applications before a decision is
finalized and then the bullet point list
on page 16 gives us
as Mr Jennings has just outlined a way
with ways we could look at that so we
could condense those bullet points down
on page 16
um and refer it back as as already
um
a grade
yes
it's cats councilor Morgan
yes thank you at the risk of showing a
pair of coke bottle shoulders I I
genuinely think that this is something
that a working group should do and
that's part of their consideration of
this is actually praise it down into the
one of the Essential Elements and come
back to us with it
and do you do you have any other news
counselor maze
yeah I I think we need to be much more
um positive on what we want
um I think we have an uh an overview
here but we need to get on and actually
produce
um a set of
guidance alongside constitutional
changes
now
and we need to have a time frame for
that piece of work to be done and it not
just be another piece of work that is
going to be done in four months time or
come back to committee I want to see
some of this work now coming back to
committee for scrutiny and then going to
full Council
not this side of Christmas unfortunately
we've not got enough time but early in
the new year so the first the first um
full council meeting in the New Year we
we mess around too much with going
backwards and forwards to working groups
I appreciate having sat on a working
group the valuable work they do but
we've got a hot we've got a halfway
house here let's get on and do this
piece of work
present it to us for then forwarding to
full Council
this Millennia thank you excellent thank
you councilor Mays so I'm coming back to
you Stuart would it be an order for us
to look at a time frame
um on the consideration
um by the working group
normally
[Music]
um
come in and the working group look at it
first and present a scrutiny plan to
committee they may suggest the time
frame and this is a 10 quite a wide
ranging matter depending what you're
looking at I mean just looking out the
planning decision making guidance in the
Constitution there at the moment is is
is quite a weighted document Hefty piece
of fact these are the matters
um yeah but there's no reason to have
something to wait for this is a good
thing that's not to latch for too long
councilor Mays thank you madam chairman
um when is our next overview on scrutiny
meeting
um because I'd like it to come back for
then
next next overview and scrutiny date
Stuart we don't think we have one yet
[Music]
um
[Music]
early to mid November
um
whether we can get a um another meeting
with a committee by the end of the
calendar year I'm not sure
um but
we could aim sorry councilor Mays uh
yeah uh through you madam chairman um
yeah I would urge you to to get one into
the calendar before the end of this uh
calendar year not Municipal year thank
you
okay so that would set a time frame then
what what are we looking at here uh
members are we thinking that a time
frame of we're in
um late October now so we're looking at
a time frame of less than two months
which is quite but we could report back
so we could report back and perhaps I
would I mean I would suggest here how do
how do members feel about a time frame
of coming up with um
if I've finalized or in terms of to
present back to committee here within
um four months councilor Mays
um could we go for an initial
um uh report back yeah six weeks from
now which would be the week commencing
the 12th of December uh it's not quite
into the last week of December which I
think would many members would find more
difficult to attend and I think this is
an important matter that needs to be
addressed and I would like to see it and
it will call it an interim report to
come back
um for uh the week commencing the 12th
of December which is approximately six
weeks from now thank you do I have a
second after that proposal
seconded thank you councilman councilor
Morgan okay so are we agreeing that by
ascent
yes great so and then we can perhaps
look at the next
um committee when we deliver the interim
report perhaps we can make a decision
then about how close we are and how much
more time is needed to bring it forward
to a committee or for Council so can I
just clarify will will the working group
have met prior to that or are we
ourselves coming up to Boiling this then
is it for us
from from that excuse me members from
from that
um
motion it would be that we would come
back with an initial report which in
fact would mean that we would have to um
an interim report rather rather than an
initial report would mean that we would
have to meet again and from there move
on from the interim to the finalized
report to to committee although of
course we might we may find that we've
reached a point where we're ready enough
to go forward so does that sound
reasonable uh Mr Jennings in in terms of
what we've resolved there
well yes in terms of getting the working
group up and running I'm sure asks are
fitting in with Council committee I
would have to defer to my my colleagues
in committee service yes
um father stretch driven resource impact
obviously
um and all that I would say is in terms
of the final output where it goes and
you rightly say you could go to council
you could go into the committee if there
are any constitutional things arising
from this committed final conclusions
well then they will have to be rooted to
okay thank you
okay so on that note I'm I'm now going
to move on sorry
okay just for clarity
um why does it have to go back to PG a
why can't it go straight to full council
is there a constitutional reason
Stuart could you help us with that
please
like this constitutional Interventional
break which would result in changes to
the Constitution
um yes you could report direct to
council but
the PGA committee is the committee with
the Constitutional remit to consider
changes to the Constitution and
recommend itself to council so
um it's a question of whether this
committee does pto's work or not or
whether there's any more work for PGA to
do let's let's see where it takes us and
make that judgment down the line
councilor Mays uh yeah whilst I accept
um what Mr Jennings has said uh that is
another layer to go through
um and I think that this uh scrutiny uh
committee
um it's not dare I say beholden to any
other committee other than for Council
and we need to be taking this
committee's work
very seriously this is a serious piece
of work Madam chairman you also
mentioned
um that you were looking at a four-month
um sort of project length uh which would
take us to sort of the end of February I
would also urge you to to look at
perhaps scheduling in even at this point
early Point
um a a final meeting for a final report
um week commencing the 27th of February
or I don't know where Easter falls uh
the um sorry I haven't got my glasses on
the 6th of March
um as the latest opportunity to have
have something that we can then report
back on decide as a committee
um and then report back I would suggest
to full Council thank you madam chairman
thank you councilman I take that on
board especially bearing in mind perder
and the elections next May so we would
have to be looking at getting that piece
of work finalized before then and as I
say maybe that when we come back then to
the interim report we may decide that
it's ready to go forward then and then
as as Mr Jennings is advised we could
look at which committee to put it
forward to or whether to put it forward
to full council at that point in time
depending on our time frames and all
other considerations
um okay so with that is everybody
satisfied now with that fantastic that's
good so we're going to move on to the
second recommendation from this report
so we've got two here rather different
recommendations now this is one where I
will ask for a second or straight away
so I'm just going to read through this
for you and it's to be found just to be
clear so we're back to where we should
be on page 11.
of the pack so
um the in the light of the scrutiny
request from councilor C Swain the
committee endorses the view of the
working group that a watching brief is
kept to monitor planning enforcement
performance data and to gain a better
understanding of certain enforcement
processes do I have a seconder for that
uh Madam chairman could I speak before
we have a second please sorry to cut
across here okay I I thought you were
seconding there Council amazed I was a
little bit confused okay before we
second that and then have to go into the
rig role of perhaps doing amendments yes
um could we have a debate about it uh
because there are a couple of points
that I would like to make thank you
that's fine um so we'll do exactly that
so I'll start with yourself then
councilman is there anybody else who
wants to speak on this item because if
there is so counselor hubner
and anybody else did you want to speak
councilor Morley
no thank you okay okay we'll start them
with yourself councilor mate uh thank
you madam chairman
um I would like to disclose that uh I am
actually um I didn't think it was
relevant but just for the for the record
uh I am the chairman for
um Central area planning
um enforcement is the bug bear of all
councilors
it is a long document that we get a
confidential document that we get
um that provides us with nothing but a
headache
a watching brief what does a watching
brief actually mean I to me it means
absolutely nothing and is a waste of
space time and money it means that we
are ignoring doing anything or bringing
anything to this scrutiny committee
I would like to see
um a report a full report on where we
are at now
what is our current level of uh
enforcement what resources we currently
have because they work Jolly hard
um
understanding exactly much of this is in
here but actually understanding as
members how this process works
how does it work from the moment that
somebody reports
um a building as not conforming to
um the regulations as set out in a
planning application
um it suggests that there'll be informal
meetings of area committees when no is
this going to be the full committees is
it just going to be chairman how is that
going to be uh that says that a schedule
appendix B3 it says about informal
committees
um
it's great at appendix be a little bit
later on in that appendix where it says
that we've already closed 170 cases but
we need to see the public needs to say
what our enforcement are doing I want to
say and I propose
that we actually have a proper full
report that is presented in January
on where we are at
so if I may just thank you very much
councilor Mays I'm going to come to Back
to You councilor Hubler but just to I'd
just like to take something from that I
us to consider whether we're looking at
here bringing this back to full overview
and scrutiny rather than the working
group
um so I don't know what I'll leave that
with you park that with you for the
moment Stuart while we go to councilor
Huebner but I'm wondering here if what
councilor Mays is actually suggesting is
it's brought back to the full overview
and scrutiny committee rather than to
the working group and which is
completely possible so we'll look at
that in a moment I'll turn to yes that's
what I'm asking that's what you're
proposing anxiety and the work of this
committee is actually recognized as
being important okay thank you thank you
councilor Mays that's very helpful
councilor hubner yeah just to add to
what uh councilman is saying what is
their plan and what's going to happen in
the future that's to be added to all
what she said because
um we don't know what's happening with
all this and it has to come back to us
so that's what I'll propose that okay so
we have a we have a proposal there from
councilor hubner to bring this item back
to
um overview and scrutiny outside the
working group back to the committee
um
yeah Madam chairman if I could clarify
um and take on um what councilor hope
and I said yes we do need a plan
absolutely we don't have one at the
moment
um we need to know how the process works
we need to know the number of current
open cases we need to know the number of
closed cases in this Municipal year at
least if we can go back further that
would be helpful we need to know what
our resources are what our resources are
now
and what they are going to be in the
future yeah
um
and how that
impacts on planning because I understand
that the lead specialist is
um a lead specialist planning he's
actually leading on enforcement so you
know is there an implication there
um and I would like to see this report
come back
um via the working group if that is the
only way that it can then can come back
to full committee it needs to come back
to full committee as councilor huben has
quite rightly said
okay thank you okay so
um I'll be going to uh Council a bill
I'm going to ask Council to Bill to
speak first
thank you madam chairman uh
it's been the bane of my life since I've
been a counselor I think the last um
plan enforcement notes we got was about
328 Pages I've lost a will to live by
Page 100.
um So within this working group I'd like
to see if it is entirely possible to
actually get the
um enforcement note this put in by Ward
so that we can go to a specific Ward and
see what items occurring to our
constituency not the world and its
mother and the whole of Malden District
it is too much
and I know they have got Staffing
problems with enforcement to something
like one point okay two five people may
I just intervene here because I do know
that um it has been offered and I think
Stuart um please correct me if I'm wrong
because this is
um my understanding it's offered that we
we could as um committee so a central
area for example meet with Enforcement
Officers to go through Enforcement cases
relevant to that committee
um but you're saying you've tried that
before my time and um and that hasn't
worked my my I'm what I'm feeling here
from the committee is that there's a
real will to bring this back to overview
and scrutiny to take it out of the
working group work plan and actually to
move it back to
um overview and scrutiny I'm very minded
um that while the watching brief is
um you know an idea that we've used
successfully
um with other items I am minded that we
are in a rapidly changing scenario so
that I know that while we've been told
for example that we are going to have
and we have other members of staff there
are also still remaining staffing issues
and because of that I think that
we and because I do take on board
um
the councilor May's comment that we need
to have the work of this committee seen
as being really crucial and important
and not
um of less importance that than some
other committees so I'm minded to say
that it should to to take it back out of
the um working group work plan and bring
it back to full committee with a report
um
now when the report comes up and that's
that's what we were looking at and the
timeliness of that bearing in mind
um the time of offices that would be
required to give us a full report
can you advise me Stewart
in terms of timelines for bringing this
back to this committee as as an item
um
on the basis that um a little more know
some Preparatory work has been done
today then obviously it will need a Time
some of the um the information
um may be available in another source in
the sense that the performance data will
routinely be reported to people in the
quarterly performance reporting round so
an up-to-date position statement will be
given then but so far as the
understanding of processes what the plan
is for the
um the increased resourcing and present
structure to converted to enforcement is
an Embrace of understanding of what the
emphasis planning services are putting
on enforcement in relation to the
revised enforcement policy which
disagreed last last year which it takes
the approach to enforcement in terms of
prioritization you know these are things
that are going to have to be explored
and reported on perhaps in the committee
with offices in support of that so um
yeah it will take a few weeks to um put
into effect
so
I would sorry councilor Morgan well I
was just wondering yeah so I'm chairman
so I'm taking your idea forward would it
be an idea to have the actual
enforcement officer come and address
yeah
yeah uh and to be too actually we put to
put to put the report in person and
allow us to um to question him or her on
that
so
any detailed report back covering these
issues will need to be supported by the
relevant officers yes
okay so and I seconded that proposal um
from councilor Morgan okay so to have
officers to attend this committee
um
that a future meeting of this committee
obviously time scales on that will have
to be looked at according to
availability yes councilor marries sorry
madam chairman
um I I think that
um let's look at
um a January
um which is two months away to prepare a
report most of it will be data some of
it will be process
um I think we should be actually trying
to fix time and Diaries
to look at this as an urgent matter this
we we get as members we get this
enforcement list every month you know as
as councilor Bill quite rightly said you
lose the will to live after page 100.
um and we can't go on like this
um and we need to be working much more
closely with our Enforcement Officers
thank you okay so looking at this
we could put an aim could we put an aim
for a time frame into into the proposal
um Stuart rather than
I think I think let's aim for because
that realistically that's that's what
we're going to come down to I think so
we would aim for it um in January in a
January meeting okay so a January
meeting is one of the things we're
striving for
um where we're going to have the
officers attend or officer or officers
with a suitable report into the current
so should we get this proposal
absolutely now down into the current
exactly what do we want we we need we
need to know exactly the the current
cases that we have
where we've come from is always useful
because it would be bigger hopefully so
so you know where we hope to be so I
know that's always an open-ended
question so what the process is the
number of cases the plan and the
resources staffing results being an
important anyone forward and for for
that report to then come back sometime
meet to end of January okay thank you
brilliant thank you so let's make sure
we've got that down let's make sure
that's what we've agreed so a seconder a
set councilor Morgan and agreed by sent
by everybody right so I'm going to draw
a line under that one there okay good
we're all satisfied fantastic so we're
going to move on to
item number seven a gender item seven
so this one
we don't have anything in the reports
pack on this this is so I'm it's a
direct recommendation to us and we don't
have any report attached so I'm just
going to go through
um that direct recommendation which is
to be found on the front page of the
agenda to consider the direct
recommendation from the performance
governance and audit committee at its
meeting on the 29th of September 2022
that the overview and scrutiny committee
review outcomes from staff exit
questionnaires as part of their work
program
so I'm going to be bold enough to ask
her a second for that do I have one
before we open the debate
yes councilor Mays
how can I second something that I have
no information on we've been provided
with nothing
um other people may want to second or
something that we've we've got
information on maybe I should have
actually taken a little more time and
gone to PG a
um minutes
um I that was but I expected it to have
been
um presented with um may I may I
interject yeah of course may I interject
councilor may my understanding is that
this is purely for us to accept this as
something that we're going to have a
report on in the future and correct
there Stuart aren't I that's exactly
what we're looking at so what we're
doing is accepting that we want to bring
this to this committee now
from my own
um research prior to the meeting I know
that there are some elements of the um
staff questionnaire that we would
potentially want to to look at without
saying well without having a report in
front of us
um
councilor hubner sorry and then I'll
come to you councilor Mays
so was this because no one else is
looking at it or well it's
not a new thing is it it's come from PG
and a for us to review those outcomes
and I'm I'm guessing that what they're
looking at is that from that taking on
that onto our
um into our work for the work work of
this committee we'd be looking at
um Coming reviewing it and coming up
with any recommendations that need to be
put in place as a result yes
councilor Mays yeah Madam chairman thank
you
um from from what you've said you've
actually clarified a little bit
um what you're asking is actually for
this
um overview and scrutiny committee to
look at a report to come forward from
yes it's an acceptance of the item it's
maybe the way that it's worded
um and I think we need to actually be a
bit more precise as you know we're
Layman uh can we get away from you know
yeah of course uh let's try and get away
from you know fancy words please use
three words rather than ten
so I mean I'm inclined to agree because
myself I did have to read this over a
few times
um my understanding is that that this
this is a report that they want to bring
to this committee for us to then
scrutinize which is absolutely perfect
and I would propose that we accept
absolutely going forward
so a second year for that I'll put
councilor Morley down this time
fantastic okay so that's agreed by
ascent and we can we can move on from
that so we come to item eight which is
any other items of business that the
chairman decides are urgent and I think
after that very fruitful discussion this
evening I can't think of any more at
this moment in time so so I certainly
didn't come with any others so so we'll
call that none so then we moved to
exclusion item um nine exclusion of the
public and press
so I I do
um remove the the committee resolves
that under section 100 a so councilor
May
[Music]
cameras have actually been and on the
sort of Switched Off
because it looks so Switched Off are we
are we actually live we should be are we
live Stuart
okay good okay I shall carry I shall
carry on now okay so I moved that the
committee members members please move
that the committee resolves that under
Section 184 of the Local Government Act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the grounds that they
involve the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph
three of part one of schedule 12a to the
ACT and that this satisfies the public
interest test do I have a seconder
councilor Morgan thank you can we agree
that by a cent
thank you okay so at this point then I
will wait for um the cameras to be
switched off